he was called America's son the heir to
Camelot and even the sexiest man alive
he was John F Kennedy jr. and like his
father he left us far too soon from
childhood when he was known as John John
he lived under a media microscope as a
young man he forged a successful career
as Assistant District Attorney of New
York co-founder of the political
magazine George and more but 17 years
ago when he was just 38 tragedy struck
Kennedy's private plane crashed into the
Atlantic killing him his wife Carolyn
Bessette and her sister Lauren a new
documentary film
I am JFK jr. offers an intimate look at
his life through those who knew him best
despite these six-pack abs and great
physique which he certainly had um and
he worked hard for and he deserved he
was not a great athlete despite all the
pictures you see or films you see up and
playing football in Central Park he was
terrible touch really played it with
such intensity and seriousness but they
say there are scho two receivers and the
job was not a go tours ever with us now
is Rosemarie Terenzi oh one of JFK
juniors closest friends and chief of
staff at George magazine she is also the
author of fairy tale interrupted about
her time with JFK jr. and joining us
from Los Angeles is Derek Murray the
film's director and producer good
morning to you both good morning good
morning
rosemary let me start with you because
you actually started at George magazine
as his personal assistant and rose to
his chief of staff and you've described
the magazine kind of as his cocoon yeah
I mean he I think that's where he fit
well first of all I think the magazine
was who he was it was celebrity and
politics sort of merging this pop
culture and any politics kind of merging
but also the staff at George kind of
closed ranks around him and we were very
protective of him so I feel like when he
came to the office it was the the one
place that he could kind of exhale let
his breath go and he could just
beautiful how did you meet we met I was
working for his partner Michael Berman
at a PR firm and John took over my
office and I wasn't very happy about it
I let him know it and I think he kind of
got a kick out of it
Derek I have to say the snippet that
we've played is so perfect because there
is this
wonderful intimate side that you'd
otherwise not really have known about
him and I was curious how did you get so
many of his close friends the roommates
the co-workers the friends to talk about
him waiting overnight it's interesting
because that's what we wanted to do we
felt that everybody knew JFK jr. but
they didn't really know him and so the
mission was to go out and put the other
cast that could tell us he's incredibly
you know passionate and intimate stories
and the process was that we started to
reach out to folks unfortunately one of
the first people that we reached out to
was Rose Marie and Rose Marie once we'd
kind of passed the litmus test and and
she understood that we wanted to create
this you know inspiring film on this
fallen hero
that she then stepped in and helped us
and we put together an amazing cast and
truly this film is is is is really
successful because this cast really
shares they really cared about this man
and it's a beautiful portrait yeah it's
interesting because you actually didn't
speak to any Kennedys for this film you
just you stuck with with close friends
yeah I know it's interesting I mean we
we started looking a lot wider
originally but once we started to put
the friends in place and we started to
get these true passionate moments and
stories we followed through with that
momentum we wanted something that was
very visceral and very at the moment as
opposed to something that might be more
of sort of the you know what you might
say that the political perspective of
JFK jr. sort of the you know this is who
he was to the Kennedys we wanted to get
deeper into his personal story rosemarie
I'm curious how did he handle all that
constant attention because you were with
him so many of those times when cameras
are swarming him it's like a paparazzi
around him all the time um you know I
think he managed to maintain a lot of
privacy I mean he lived his life a
certain way and he but John was famous
from the day he was born so that wasn't
strange to him that was normal to him
and that was something that he didn't
see as a burden he saw it as a privilege
as an opportunity as a way to you know
do things that were great and have
people pay attention to that and shy
away from talking about his childhood no
he didn't shy away from it he would you
know bring it up as we all do you know
in passing but it wasn't something that
we sat down and discussed you know as an
historical you know event it was just
very regular the way we - all talk about
our parents
our childhood and our siblings and that
was really something amazing about him
you he was he was towards the end of his
life he it looked like he was preparing
himself for politics do you think that
was inevitable I think yeah it was
discussed and I think he would have
eventually I think he wanted to make
George magazine a success first because
I think that John is very conscious of
I'm not just gonna run on my meaning and
I but I think he would have if he when
he did I think he would have run for
governor governor of New York yeah yeah
Rosemarie Terenzi Oh Derek Murray in Los
Angeles thank you both so much
I am JFK jr. is now in select theaters
and premieres on Spike TV on August 1st